I was thinking about the issue of
discrimination in relationship to sex
because I've been thinking a lot about
discrimination lately because everybody
thinks discrimination is a bad idea,
which is a very stupid proposition
because you're discriminating all the
time and the most fundamental form of
discrimination is choice of sexual
partner.
And so you might say,
well why should that even be allowed?
Because it is the most fundamental form
of discrimination.
So for example,
almost everyone is racially prejudice
when it comes to sexual partners.
So you think,
well,
is that,
uh,
what about,
are you do use age as an exclusionary
criteria?
Probably do use physical attractiveness
only in so far as you're able,
right?
You use it completely.
If you could get away with it roughly
speaking,
but you can't because the most
attractive people aren't going to be
anywhere near you.
So you can't do it.
But you'd like to.
Health yes.
Strength.
Yes.
Wealth,
yes.
Education,
definitely.
So it's unbelievably discriminatory.
And so you might say,
well why is that justifiable?
And it seems to me that it's something
like,
well,
you get to say no to me if I get to say
no to you.
It's something like that.
We've agreed that everybody gets to
discriminate on that basis and because
everybody can do it then it's fair.
It's something like that.
It's very much we're thinking about,
you know,
I don't know if you know this,
but in Huxley's brave new world where
the family had been completely
demolished rate and children were
conceived in bottles and given an
produced in factories.
So the whole idea of the relationship
between sex and procreation had become a
taboo.
One of the Mantras,
the slogans of the society was everyone
belongs to everyone else.
And so it was actually a social full
pause to refuse to sleep with someone
just as it was a social for Paul to have
any exclusionary relationship.
Because another thing that you might
notice is that there's nothing more
discriminatory than falling in love with
someone.
It's like you're special and all the
rest of you know.
So it's the ultimate exclusionary act.
Right?
And yet we presume that that's an
acceptable,
not only acceptable.
We demand that as a,
as a right and well,
that's where thinking about a lot.